Fake technology is incredible.
It's brought us lifelike versions
of Tom Cruise doing coin tricks.
You probably seen Jerry
Seinfeld costarring in Pulp Fiction.
It can be amusing and funny.
It can also be really creepy and dark
as our Donyell Sullivan.
As previously reported,
the technology
has been turned against women
to make revenge porn.
U.S.
intelligence has warned
about the potential threat
to national security posed by deepfakes.
Tonight,
Dhoni is back with a look at how
I can fake our own voices,
including my own
Hello.
Hi, Mom. Hi.
How are you?
Does my voice sound different to you?
Yeah.
I just thought that you should do this
as the only two American
because this is not actually me.
This is a voice made by computer
Are you serious?
Yeah, I. I'm sorry.
There has been an explosion in fake audio
and voices
being generated
through artificial
intelligence technology.
This is an A.I.
cloned version of Walter White's voice.
cloned version of Leonardo
DiCaprio's voice.
All you need is a couple of minutes
recording of anyone's voice,
and you can make it seem
like they have said just about anything.
Even Anderson Cooper.
We've come here to UC
Berkeley today to talk to Hani.
Fareed, a digital forensic expert,
about just
how easy
it is to put words
into other people's mouths.
It's a lot of fun.
Sure. But it's also really scary.
I think once you put aside
that gee whiz factor,
I don't think it takes a long time
to look at the risks.
This is Wolf Blitzer.
And Fareed, you're in The Situation Room
That's that's good for you.
By uploading just a few minutes of me
and some of my colleagues
voices to an air audio service,
I was able to create
some convincing fakes,
including this one of Anderson Cooper.
Donie O'Sullivan is a real piece of
that's lie.
Those are really. That's right.
That's good.
Yeah.
Anderson is really good, man,
because Anderson doesn't
have a stupid Irish accent.
The technology did struggle
with my Irish accent,
but we decided to put it
to the ultimate test with my parents.
I am about to try to call my mom
back in Ireland.
And see if I can trigger with this voice.
I think I'm going to be successful.
I'm nervous.
I'm like, my hands are
all right.
Hello.
Hi, Mom.
Hi, Tony. How are you?
Just finished shooting our story here.
I'm going to the airport in a while,
but it seems to be a delay in the phone.
Tony.
Can I say a quick hello to Dad?
Yep.
How you doing it?
Hi, Dad.
Oh, hi.
How are you?
Well, I'll have just finished
shooting our story here.
I'm going to the airport in a while.
Oh, he'll come back.
I could, you know,
carry playing this weekend.
Airplane tattoo on the same day
my dad went on to have a conversation
with the air
Tony about how Carrie, our home
football team had a game that weekend.
Eventually, I had to come clean.
Dad, I'll give you a call
better later on.
Could you just put me back on
to Mom for a second?
My parents knew
something was off, but ultimately,
they still fell for it.
Some of the don't do that,
but it was like.
It was like
your voice was a little too low
where it is so very serious.
Yeah, seriously, though,
because I went, oh,
my heart was half
the curse on the side of the white.
The very funny
and the it that is on here.
All right, I put it.
I'll call you later.
That is over, right?
This is not classic The mom is like,
something's wrong with my son.
The dad is like, everything's fine.
I'd like to close out today's ceremony
with a question.
If you were given a choice,
would you choose to have unlimited bacon?
But no more video games?
Would fake Biden
and Trump recordings going viral online?
Fred says
this could be something to be wary of.
Going into the 2024 election.
When we enter this world
where anything can be faked,
any image, any audio, any video,
any piece of text,
nothing has to be real.
We have what's called the liar's dividend
which is anybody can deny reality
what a flood of new A.I.
tools are releasing online.
He says companies
developing this
powerful technology
need to think of its potential
negative effects.
There is no online and offline world.
There's one world,
and it's fully integrated.
When things happen on the Internet,
they have real implications
for individuals, for communities,
for societies, for democracies.
And I don't think we as a field
have fully come to grips
with our responsibility here.
In the meantime,
I'll continue annoying my colleagues
here this time Anderson said.
I've been doing this a long time.
I have to say
Donie O'Sullivan
is probably the best in the business.
Incredible.
That's very kind of him to say, really.
Well,
you know, you should be honored really.
I would never say that.
You know, you are.
So, I mean, this is fascinating to me.
It's amazing it's funny.
It is also scary.
I mean, as you point out in that piece,
you could take somebody's
voice, call their your mom and, you know,
have some scam against her
saying you were in trouble
and needed you to wire money immediately.
Yeah.
I mean,
my parents are never going to believe
when I pick up the phone,
they are so sweet
up the phone to them again,
like is this really daunting?
But look, you know,
we had a bit of fun there,
but this technology is so crazy powerful
to create the deepfake of you.
We only need in a minute or two of audio.
That's incredible.
And you could immediately start typing,
putting words in your mouth.
Yeah.
Look, obviously
as we go into 20, 24 election,
think about the role
that audio has played
in previous campaigns,
the Access Hollywood tape,
the Romney tape,
the percentage
and even the kind of the Watergate
tapes, all that
sort of stuff, as well as,
just as you mentioned,
the kind of scams
tricking people and vice it a report
where they were able
to break into a bank account
that had a voice,
I think of it from a cyber infection,
somebody who has died
and a loved one who wants to hear their,
you know,
their loved one's voice and even,
you know, commune with them.
That's the potential in the future
that would be easy to do now.
And as well with something like chatbot
where you could mimic
what they would say.
Yeah, the two of them together.
It's incredible. I don't know.
Sullivan, thanks so much.